c'est très important de cyclotrons parce
que c'est ce qui va nous permettre de
produire les minimes radioactifs ce
qu'on appelle les ratios traceur qu'on
va pouvoir injecter au patient et faire
l'imagerie tempo qui soit et scan au
tpir donc ça permet de diagnostiquer les
cancers de façon plus précoce et de
façon plus précise concernant cyclotron
c1 comme un laboratoire pharmaceutique
en fait qui profite des médicaments
voilà faut bien comprendre que c'est une
machine qui produit des traceurs
radioactifs en accélérant des particules
qui va créer la radioactivité ensuite ça
t'a radioactivité va être cumulé un
traceur qu'on va pouvoir injecter au
patient et faire les images grâce au
thème scan nous ce n'est pas la machine
qui permet de faire les images ci-contre
ont permis de produire les doses et
ensuite c'est une autre machine qui
permet de parler l'image qui est le tep
scan ou le tpir